- Get your mom on the phone.
Let me talk to your mom.
- [Jeffery] Nah, she's
not with me right now.
- Okay, okay.
- I'm on vacation.
- (laughing) What are
you on vacation for, man?
(claps)
(epic rap music)
- [Gary] You've got your perspective.
(audience cheering)
I just wanna be happy.
Don't you wanna be happy?
(telephone ringing)
- [Jeffery] Hello?
- Hello this is Gary Vaynerchuk.
- [Jeffery] Oh hey, how you doin'?
- I'm good my guy, how are you?
- [Jeffery] I'm good, I'm good, I'm good.
I was just watching you, oh my gosh.
- What's your name?
- [Jeffery] I'm, Jeffery Ford.
- Jeffrey, where are you from?
- [Jeffery] From, New York.
- Good my guy, anything
I can answer for you?
- [Jeffery] Yeah, so I'm in the,
like I get it, but I'm tryin' to push,
like lookin' out, I was tryin'
to put to the doin' part.
My uncle, he has a car
dealership right now.
And, I get the marketing.
It's just, I don't know where to start
because I'm not so into
marketing right now.
I just know, just by
watching you, on what to do.
I just don't know how to start with him.
- When you say you get it,
but you don't know what to do,
does that mean theoretically at the macro
you understand that marketing works,
but you don't know how
to tactically execute it?
Or, you don't know how to convince him
to let you tactically execute it?
- [Jeffery] No, he wants me to do it.
I just don't know where to start.
I know I should start a Facebook
page and stuff like that,
but as far as, 'cause he has a small shop.
He doesn't have a big shop.
- Alright, I'm gonna give you,
you got a pen or you got your
phone to write this down?
I'm gonna give you a URL.
I'm gonna make you read this 86 page deck.
You ready?
- Uh-huh.
- It's Gary, it's...
I put out an 86 page deck
that explains the secret.
- [Jeffery] Oh, is it the content model?
- Yeah. Have you gone through it?
- [Jeffery] Oh, no I
haven't gone through it.
- Good, that's what you want to do.
You wanna go through
that free content model,
and then execute against it
and look at it and do that.
- [Jeffery] All right and then,
but what if I have my parents,
this forcing me to go back to school?
Should I still
worry about that or just focus
on trying to help my uncle?
- Well why?
- That's my whole--
- That makes sense,
break this down for me.
Why would you listen to your parents?
And I'm not saying that as a joke.
I'm saying, do you live in their house
and you have to...
I'm always fascinated by why one
would listen to their parents.
The two reasons that people would listen
to their parents are one,
they live in their house,
or their parents are giving them money
and they need that room for money.
Two, they just deeply love their parents
and they're just scared to let them down.
Do you have a third one?
Is yours one, is it two, is it a mix?
- [Jeffery] It's a mix
of one because it's like,
- Well, that's not a mix, that's just one.
(laughing)
- [Jeffery] Okay so,
I moved out of my mom's
house when I was 18.
- Okay.
- And I had my own apartment
since 19
to 21 right now.
But because of a health
issue, I had to move back.
- For your health issue or hers?
- Mine.
- Okay, are you better now?
- Yeah, I'm better now.
- Good.
- [Jeffery] But, it's just,
I wanna go back to being on my own,
but it's just the fact that
now I'm living with her.
She wants me to do what I wanna do,
but then again it's like
you know that always,
"You know you gotta go back to school?
"You know you gotta go back to school?"
- I know, she bought into the propaganda
like everybody else.
Look honestly, I don't think
you should go back to school.
- [Jeffery] Right, and that's what I keep
tellin' her because like--
- Then, that's it.
- I'm not watching--
- But that's it.
Listen, the biggest thing I
want you to do, straight up,
is start flipping and making money.
- Right.
- Straight up,
you can be out of your moms crib
in five minutes if you just
went to the thrift store,
the dollar store, eBay, Kmart, Walmart.
- [Jeffery] And, that's what I did too.
I did the whole eBay
thing, I was doing good.
It's just the fact that
when shipping and all
that stuff, like that,
that had me restricted.
- Charge shipping!
Charge it, my man, you're giving
me all the cliché answers.
- All right.
- Charge shipping,
work 18 hours a day.
You know how you make more?
People are like, "Yo Gary Vee,
"I made $3000 on eBay this month.
"How do I make more?"
I'm like, "How much did you work?"
They're like,
"Oh, I don't know, like nine hours?"
I'm like cool, work 18 hours.
Work 36 hours,
work 72 hours,
work 144 hours, work 288 hours!
- [Jeffery] So basically, I'm just working
in my head and just do?
- Yeah dude, that's it.
You just, honestly stay right there.
You just cracked it.
And if I can get you
to actually believe it
and not just say it.
You're in your fuckin' head.
You're debating, you're
playing life in your head,
not actually living it.
- [Jeffery] Right, and that's what I hate!
'Cause I know exactly what to do,
it's just like that push.
I don't want to wait 'til
something bad happens.
- You are though.
You're being passive.
(Jeffrey sighs)
- [Jeffery] Yeah, I got to change that.
- The bigger question is, why?
The bigger question is,
this is why I got myself into the whole,
do you give a about other
people's opinions, you know?
- Right.
- The biggest thing
young people get caught up on is
(chuckling) they'll make $400 flipping
and then they'll go buy
some new Off-Whites.
- [Jeffery] Yeah, and
that's the thing too.
I don't wanna be caught up in that mental.
I started just,
I bought, I made my own shirts,
so I just wear my shirts every day.
- (laughing) Good!
Good, I like that!
- I'm not trying to--
- Yeah man, listen, listen.
- All that stuff.
- The person that flosses last, wins.
- Damn, that was tough.
- It's super tough!
- That was tough.
- Because everyone, if
you look at everybody,
the reason you reacted that way
is 'cause everybody's
playing it the reverse.
- [Jeffery] Right.
- I was, I anti-flossed in my 20s.
I didn't buy anything, I didn't go out,
I didn't do anything.
I put down foundation.
- Yeah and that's too.
Damn.
And, that's the thing
that I learned from you.
I started to realize like damn,
do I really need to go to the club?
Do I really need to go to that party?
- And you know what,
I'll tell you what happens.
Now, you watch a little Gary Vee,
you get a little motivated,
you decide to actually
work on Friday night.
But then you wake up Saturday, right?
And you're feeling good,
and then you grab your phone
and you go on Instagram,
and the first thing you see
is your boys or the people you look up to
in the club, pretty girls,
- Right, money.
- Jewelry, money.
- And all of the sudden you're FOMO'd out.
- [Jeffery] Yeah, I think I
get a little bit of that, I do.
But I try not to worry about it
because it's like dang, I
got Gary Vee motivating me,
but then I got my mom telling
me to go back to school.
That, I'm just--
- Your mom's wrong, I'm right.
Man, what are you gonna do at school?
Explain to me what's
happening with you in school.
(Jeffery laughing)
Where the are you goin'
and where, you're gonna collect debt
from some college and
get no job because of it.
- Exactly, exactly.
- Get your mom on the phone.
Let me talk to your mom.
- Nah,
she's not with me right now.
- Okay, okay.
- I'm in, I'm on vacation.
- Okay, (laughing) what are
you on vacation for, man?
Listen, we're, yo.
- I just thought I'd--
- Yo, do me a favor.
Email Gary@VaynerMedia.
You're comin' here, you're
spending one day here.
You're coming here, you're
coming to Vayner Media one day.
I'm gonna put you with the crew.
I need to get you rewired.
- All right.
- Gary@VaynerMedia.
See ya.
- What do I put in the title?
- Say I'm the dude
that's gonna get rewired.
(laughing)
That.
- All right.
- All right man, see ya.
That's a great, I'm,
those one more phone
calls always work out.
I want that whole video on YouTube.
Yo, Instagram, what'd
you think about that?
(laughing)
But what's amazing about that is that
phone call is 90% of it.
And by the way, everybody
who's razzing in the comments,
that's just his way of communicating.
Valley girls got that.
Yeah that's, bro dudes,
frat dudes got that.
Emo dudes got that.
- Yeah, most of--
- Yeah, he did it in the
culture urban dude voice
and terminology and vibe,
but don't judge everybody
because all of you are
doing the same your way.
Colorado skiing dudes doin' this.
Like don't judge everyone's.
99, I'm watchin' you.
I'm watching you and 99% of
you are playing that same game.
You may use different adjectives,
different terminology,
you might have different kinds
of friends and circumstances,
but in your dome, in your framework,
in your execution, that's you.
99% of you.
And we're gonna smoke you the out in 2019.
(background laughter)
See ya.
- Subscribe, like, comment.
- Oh yeah!
Subscribe, like and comment.
(background laughter)
I don't even do the best
practices on YouTube.
But we will, thank you D Rock.
Subscribe, like and comment.
Bunch you watch in the comment, content,
and you're not subscribed.
The amount of you that...
I DM the bunch of cool people,
and they're all like huge fans.
I'm like you don't even
follow me on Instagram.
I didn't even know you knew.
Like the amount of you watching,
listening right now.
I know this is gonna be a podcast.
The amount of you who are listening
to the podcasts right now,
and you're not subscribed to the podcast,
so you pinged in the
morning, is ludicrous.
This is the year of
subscribe, comment and share.
- Rate and review.
- Rate and review too.
And pass on to a friend that is confused
about what's going on over here.
That's right.
All of you have a Gary
Vee hater in your life.
Grab their hand and help them.
Bring them over here.
See ya.
(light hip-hop music)